before you got into comedy you were a
physical therapist yes what was that
like so it's it's an interesting
profession because believe it or not I
mostly work with Kids Pediatrics but
there was six months where I was
Orthopedics and one day a guy came in
with like excruciating back pain right
all this back pain whatever and I
couldn't reproduce it part of your job
as a physical therapist is trying to
reproduce the pain and then you can
narrow down well it's got to be that's
got to be that and so I couldn't do it I
was a new new brand new therapist so I
called him my boss who's got 20 had 20
years experience
so he goes you know what pull down your
pants he literally what what was going
to turn out to be herpes he had he had
herpes chlamydia and I think gonorrhea
all at the same time
what he was doing was paying extra he
was paying thousands of dollars extra to
have sex with prostitutes with no condom
you would never you would walk past this
guy he was like a soccer dad from Long
Island you're you're a doctor yes you
have a doctorate degree how do you make
that leap so what makes you decide do
people do people where you work say hey
man you're funny so what happened was is
I was on this show on MTV called Guy
Code and Geico got really popular
amongst high school college kids in 2013
and I was simultaneously doing physical
therapy and comedy and I got on this guy
coach show and I was starting to get
recognized by these young moms who I was
treating their kids in school they were
like are you are you a guy from Guy Code
I was like oh yeah and you know I
remember my principal of the school
watched the one episode she watched it
was a three-minute piece where I went
over the Geico to hiding your boner in
public and she was like you can't do
treat little kids and also be talking
about how to hide your bonus so she made
me choose right then and there and she I
remember vividly her saying exact quote
she's like Chris you're an idiot if you
try to pursue comedy
idiot she taught word for it she was
like you're an idiot she was like we
have another guy who does this comedy
stuff who works in the school district
and you know he's never going to make it
you're not going to make it she was like
I don't mean to crush your dreams but
this is not going to happen so you you
have a great job here making 58 000 a
year with full health benefits she's
like so you should stay and if my mom
said the same but my dad was like go for
it my dad was like let it rip you can
live in my basement in Staten Island
you're gonna never regret you're gonna
regret it my dad's like every day I wake
up and I regret not trying out for the
Yankees I was like you're fat you've had
diabetes since you're 25 years old we're
never going to make the Yankees but I
took he kind of blessed me and was like
just go and then I went left Physical
Therapy that day about two weeks later
MTV gave me like an overall contract to
like just do comedy with MTV and like
doubled my physical therapy salary so I
never looked back
thank you